dans la dans la dans le dans le monde
médiatique aujourd'hui il y a pas une
personne de la notoriété de la jeunesse
de Delphine qui a dit moi je vote pour
ma pour Marine Le Pen encore une fois tu
déforme mes propos puisque je ne l'ai
jamais dit mais effectivement mais
globalement pardon tous les gens tous
les gens disent non mais je vais vous
dire il vote à gauche vous arrêtez pas
de rigoler les artistes ont votes à
gauche donc ils sont cool quand ceux qui
ont dit on vote pour Sarko ils ont été
carrément placardisés c'est la
jurisprudence modèle donc moi je trouve
excuse-moi moi je trouve que c'est
injuste parce que quelque part on dit à
32% des gens qui ont voté pour des
l'extrême droite en gros vous avez pas
le droit de le dire parce que finalement
voilà vous c'est donc c'est très
hypocrite donc moi je suis à la raison
de dire ça c'est dégueulasse
concrètement moi ça me fait très bizarre
d'être là en tant qu'invité pourquoi
donc là je suis puni pourquoi et je suis
mis je suis mise au placard parce que
quoi j'étais trop courageuse j'étais
trop authentique j'ai dit ce que je
pensais pourquoi parce que j'ai fait mon
travail de chroniqueur on sait très bien
qu'ici le but c'est de donner notre avis
sur la téléréalité sur des faits de
société et en ce moment sur de la
politique donc en fait j'ai juste bien
fait mon job j'ai et sur la chicha aussi
donc en fait j'ai juste bien fait mon
job et là voilà on me met au placard
pourquoi parce que j'ai utilisé mon
droit de liberté de penser et de
m'exprimer et d'ailleurs à ce propos
donc du coup je devais faire toute la
semaine vous le savez on en a parlé
ensemble donc concrètement je perds des
émissions donc je perds de l'argent et
donc c'est le prix ça ce que je perds
c'est le prix de la liberté donc
aujourd'hui en France la liberté c'est
quoi comme liberté égalité
aujourd'hui je suis sanctionné et je
perds de l'argent par rapport à ça c'est
le prix de la liberté et je vais le
redire pour que tout le monde le
comprenne on a fait beaucoup de blagues
sur Bernard porte-parole du gouvernement
et ça pas pendant
la période présidentielle ça fait
longtemps qu'on en parle donc quelque
part tu es connoté moi j'ai jamais parlé
de présidentielle de politique mais là
j'en parle parce que c'est le moment
voilà et dans trois jours j'en parlerai
plus parce que voilà c'est fini et
d'ailleurs à partir de ce ce soir je
n'en parle plus ce que je veux dire
c'est que moi je ne suis pas porte
parole du gouvernement donc pas
d'Emmanuel Macron donc ça tout le monde
l'a compris je ne suis pas non plus
porte-parole de Marine Le Pen je suis
juste une porte-parole des Français qui
ont été mécontents et qui sont déçus de
ce quinquennat c'est tout c'est tout
voilà c'est c'est important quelle
audition à cause de ça je trouve c'est
très très triste pour la démocratie non
mais surtout il y a 32% des gens qui ont
voté globalement pour ces idées et en
gros on leur dit mais en fait si vous
votez pour ses idées vous pouvez pas
apparaître dans les médias parce que
finalement ça pue en fait parce que vous
êtes vous êtes soupçonné de racisme et
tout ça donc moi je pense que ça c'est
un vrai problème il faut combattre les
idées entre les personnes
franchement je la connais bien je pense
qu'on serait pas aussi amis et elle
serait pas dans l'émission vous savez on
a des valeurs ici dans l'émission qui
sont claires tous ensemble ici on le
sait donc voilà donc je pense que
Delphine voilà elle serait pas dans
l'émission je pense que Delphine tu as
voulu être le
ça va les répécresse si elle s'en était
mieux sortie j'aurais dit pourquoi pas
le côté maternel le côté les femmes qui
ont des couilles on aime ça et on sait
que les femmes qui ont des couilles
que certains hommes et pourquoi est-ce
que j'ai dit par exemple maman des maman
des Français parce que ça m'a fait
penser par exemple à Angela Merkel on
dit Mouti d'un national ça m'a fait
penser en Thaïlande
en Israël aussi c'était c'était la maman
de l'Israël c'est la même chose c'est
pour ça en fait que j'ai que j'ai
utilisé cette rhétorique